So how do we fix this problem with our boys?
How do we fix it? What do we do?
How do we keep this from happening?
Because this has become a just widespread,
systemic issue with our boys and guns and schools.
So, um,
I think there's two ways of fixing it.
Again, I'm not a professional.
I'm just a mom with two boys
and who's done a lot of research about parenting.
Okay, uh,
but I'm a layman, I'm not an expert.
These are my opinions. First,
at an individual family level,
you have to raise your voice the same way you would raise a daughter.
And I don't mean with, like,
dresses and makeup. Although if he's into that.
Go fucking on, Bud.
Have a great time. However,
what I mean is being able to identify emotions
and the entire wide range of emotions, um,
accept those emotions as innately human,
and then have healthy coping mechanisms
for when those emotions get to be overwhelming.
Now, you can start this as a toddler.
I have a two and a half year old right now
who's having a really hard time controlling his hands when he's angry.
I'm sure a lot of people with two and a half year old
or three year old boys can understand.
He's hitting me, he's hitting his siblings,
he's throwing things. And all of this is developmentally appropriate.
Right, but what we don't want this to do is continue on.
We do not Want to accept this as just always,
just boys being boys. He's just rough,
you know? It's okay.
It's not okay.
So I have had for years because I have two older children.
I have books on what to do with big feelings.
We have sensory toys, balls you can squeeze when you're angry.
We have had multiple talks.
When he goes through a tantrum and he hits me,
I do not hit him back. I do not meet violence with violence.
We don't use violence as a tool of coercion or control in this house.
Because why would I teach my children to use violence as a tool?
No idea. Um.
We have coping skills. We have calm corners.
We have discussions. We have discussions because it takes repetition.
It is a practice. It is really hard
and almost impossible for a toddler at that developmental age
to control their field, their.
Their body in that moment.
However, repetition of a lesson will stay with them,
and they will eventually learn.
And he's already starting to get it.
He apologizes after he is violent,
I walk away. If he's violent once with me,
I put him down. I walk away.
I said, you are not gonna hurt Mama.
Mmm. You're not allowed to hurt anyone,
and I'm not gonna let you hurt me,
so I'm gonna go.
My two and a half year old can now tell me the difference between
when he's feeling frustrated,
when he's feeling sad. And when he's feeling angry,
I know grown men who can't do that.
Now, systemically,
we have a problem with our idea of masculinity
because it fits in such a tight,
narrow box that almost no man can actually fit it,
because it's inhuman.
Our idea of masculinity is inhumane because it cuts people off,
male people, from the wide range of human emotions
and their ability to express them.
How many times have we seen people disparage men who cry?
Just look at Tim Walters speech.
Look how many people were talking about what a sissy his son is
for being overcome with emotion.
That is the world we live in,
where a boy crying with pride for his father
is considered a sign of weakness,
considered a sign of being emasculated.
If you don't express your emotions,
they will express themselves through you.
And we see this through the male mental health crisis
that we have in this country
because we have massive rates of men unaliving themselves.
And that is toxic emotion faced inwards.
And then we also have an epidemic of violence against women,
against children and in schools by young angry men.
Because the only emotion they know how to express is anger.
And they are either gonna bring it in or they're gonna push it out.
And if they push it out too far,
they're gonna take everyone with them.
We have to allow our boys to be humans.
And we have to allow Our men to be humans.
And we have to stop acting like being human is innately feminine,
wild, uh,
that being human is innately emasculating,
that being human is innately weak.
Those are the messages that boys get when they go into this world.
When they are told that they can be rageful,
be angry, be tough.
But, my god,
don't be sad, don't be weak.
Don't need your parents, don't need help.
My god, you're supposed to be the man of the house.
That's insane. That's insane.
We are trying to train boys to be robots,
and instead, what we're getting is killers.
Confidence comes from knowing who you are
and having control over who you are
and how you express yourself
and the way you carry yourself in this world.
And insecurity is where violence and rage and anger and entitlement.
All of that comes from
either feeling things you're not supposed to feel,
um, or having no outlet for the feelings that you can recognize.
We need to do better at both.